scientists are on their way to Jupiter
but it's a little disappointing today
the Jupiter icy moons Explorer or juice
for short is set to make its way to the
gas giant but there's a problem juice
won't reach its destination until 2031.
that's eight years away it's never taken
a space probe this long to get to
Jupiter by comparison the Juno
spacecraft made it there in just five
years this is because Jupiter is
hundreds of millions of kilometers
further away from us than it normally is
and you can't travel there in a straight
line no you have to maneuver your way
through the solar system and use other
planets gravity to boost your speed and
direction this is called gravity assist
these Maneuvers are necessary for
Journeys that require too much fuel or
juice the juice is good